I like to reacted a play so what am I
we're gonna look at some of your films
and we're gonna see what could accept
them and then you try and guess with
comedy
given the fun it has drinking its own
bong water it's a much it's a bit much
to describe the film as a great critique
of institutionalized sexism assembly 9%
and I'm amazed it was only 79% this was
a very good film I'll actively acted
Appalachia
what am i a feline with a live body Wall
Street that was a wolf howl you could
have howled at least I should have
called
okay you got me with the cat the claw
had me okay yeah I don't want to review
the lank you know I want to live in it
and invite you to live in it very high
number of certified fresheners is it a
place no well then I have no idea
Paddington too loved Matthew McConaughy
though I'm not convinced he knew the
cameras were rolling this that's a great
review no matter what film is a circuit
80% certified fresh' so eighty-three
percent certified yeah you're not 70
yeah mmm give me another hit
yes Matthew Mike I knew the cameras my
canoe the cameras rolling on its a
couple others I didn't know be TVs you
seduce a bad love life and even worse
underwear has never looked so good
Oh Bridget Bridget yeah that's 81
percent certified pressure is that all
like the moustache brought it by Matthew
McConaughey's character
this movie is sleazy amusing and quite
quite awesome 91% certified fresh' I'm
going to act the pipe
very good action I'll do it again yes
please Oh Daisy confuses think I
wouldn't gone out without your anchor
it'll be a lot cooler if he did let us
praise brothers and sisters the era of
the Meccano since you were awfully good
ninety-three percent fresh Oh 93 I don't
have any that high who looked in the
film rather like the award you won for
it my Dallas buyers club in more heart
spirit Oscar you got me when you said
you look like one Guinea Oscar all right
right just okay all right I walked into
the theater exhausted and pissed off and
I left grinning like it in this one 64%
fresh only six for your lowest numbers
much to you
yeah actors is that love Love Actually
without a word really good really good
good talk about Michael Caine Michael
Caine I
Makana his facial hair is his best
acting prop it seems to exist only to
trap spittle after eating roasted meat
I'm afraid only 42 percent this is a pre
signature rain of fire
[Music]
so refreshingly incisive is granting
that for the first time you'll probably
appeal more to guys then to their
girlfriends who dragged them to this
movie for the hue factor oh yeah that
can only be one film is that about a boy
that is about it oh yeah I really tried
to get that but you got that one from me
yeah I tried to get that movie we're
getting better at guessing 93 percent
certified fresh' huh
it was a very good film we had almost
identical careers in some way did you
notice that he king of rom-coms for how
long oh I don't know yeah too long quite
a few can I talk to this hon thank the
Lord
mmm the most brilliant editing of the
year revs you up as it interlaces the
apex of love stories and when explodes
into a giant orgasm of emotional and
physical moviemaking only to roll over
lighter cigarette and stop paying
attention to you that's quite the
compliment that I'm very surprised it's
a it's 72 percent it's fresh but I would
have thought it'd be much higher this is
a very good film can you give me a
little acting it very difficult to do
interstellar yes I thought that have
been much higher dude
yeah you know what that movie is for me
more people now come to me years after
two years up to them and are biblically
attractive that done like I've seen it
six times it's my favorite film ever you
know you have something right away when
they come on opening weekend feel it
some of those years later yeah yeah why
are you whispering they can't hear you
this is the kind of movie where the big
scene is a man shot out of a cannon into
a vat of ice cream oh yes it's going to
have a low score isn't it
yes amongst it when you compare it to
the rest of yours I think it had a
really little
42% err oh not so bad you got to be Mike
24 oh I dunno what it is
I'd say it's it's two weeks notice two
weeks no bollocks yeah we both know we
both know miss Andy yeah yeah yeah
congratulations on the baby
what baby this is closer Close
Encounters of the Third Kind for the
x-files generation true tech no 63
percent fresh I just said interstellar
close it kind of third count forward
shockingly good nippy touchy oh you just
I'm magic magic magic magic I already
said Magic Mike come on stick it on Tom
Tom Tom contact you more on contact
yeah what what are you writing
the usual nouns adverbs adjectives here
and there
alright that's it we're done there you
go Wow
[Music]